[Musique]
une soirée tout enfant phare pour le
solide deuxième mandat de gouverneur de
Rome descente
la liberté dit-il est ici pour rester
voilà qui enchante ces partisans qui
veulent le garder encore pour 4 ans
le républicain de 44 ans a commencé sa
carrière politique en 2012 comme
représentant au Congrès engagé dans
l'armée où il a servi en Irak et à
Guantanamo il est aussi diplômé de
l'université de Yale et de Harvard
mais en 2018 il démissionne du Congrès
pour tenter sa chance au poste de
gouverneur de la Floride
c'est là qu'il obtient le soutien de
Donald Trump alors président
il reprend alors tous les thèmes chers à
Donald Trump dans ses publicités
électorales
[Musique]
sa famille mais
lui avec seulement 4 dixièmes pour cent
de plus que son adversaire démocrate run
descentis et Donald Trump sont deux
hommes au diapason jusqu'à en avoir les
mêmes postures
habitué de Fox News le gouverneur
républicain parle toujours de son cheval
de bataille la liberté
il refuse ainsi de confiner les
Floridiens pendant la pandémie et il
déteste les masques
même pendant ce point de presse
lorsqu'il critique ses étudiants
sa croisade républicaine l'amène aussi
sur le terrain de l'éducation
sexuelles et donnent davantage de
pouvoir aux parents d'élèves sur leur
éducation
tout comme Donald Trump une de ses
cibles préférées les médias
il se permet ici de donner un petit
cours accéléré sur comment les remettre
à leur place
sa femme qui est ici lui donne aussi un
coup de pouce sur le terrain politique
avec des publicités très efficaces pour
rappeler le passé de son mari au service
du pays son amour de la famille mais
aussi son courage et son aide quand elle
était frappée d'un cancer du sein
aujourd'hui
galvanise les foules aux côtés de son
époux
où il se présente comme un combattant
que Dieu a créé le huitième jour et des
plus surprenante
il n'en fallait pas plus pour que Donald
Trump excédé par la popularité du
gouverneur se moque de lui
strumpetsident qui se fait talonner de
plus en plus par descentis pour
l'investiture à la présidentielle dans
deux ans
n'essaye pas de cacher certaines
ambitions
devraient suivre selon lui
mais loin des tumultes politiques sur le
bord de l'océan ceux qui se disent plus
à gauche ne sont toujours pas vendus aux
républicains ni pour Trump ni pour
descente
celle-ci ne voteraient ni pour l'un ni
pour l'eau
[Applaudissements]
bientôt un coup de circuit en sautant
prochainement dans la grande arène
présidentielle les paris sont ouverts